okay you got eyes on the bar
yep
here it goes
and i got the dealer
nino they're heading your way
they're here you should have eyes on the
merchandise
i sure do
was that a gunshot
yeah they shot the dealer
that is so unprofessional
there's a lot of them
can we do this we can't afford not to
nina you good yeah let's do it great
whenever you're ready kevin what are you
guys thinking for dinner tonight how
about my whole family
[Music]
hey guys what you got in the
oh
stolen marshall mdi-101 m9 multi-rocket
shoulder launchers nice
my buddies and i have been looking all
over town for this have you been
hoarding
see we need them for our startup it's a
criminal empire
um
[Music]
one two three
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
you should buckle up
[Applause]
[Music]
get the [ __ ] away from my friends
[Music]
there you go the next saints row and
joining me now is one of the stars of
saints row bryce charles bryce welcome
to opening night live thanks for having
me uh this is an exciting announcement
uh we just want to know what can you
tell us about the new saints row we see
you there behind us right your character
well before i get into all that i have
to say i am just so excited to be here
and i am incredibly proud and honored to
be a part of this game and to work with
the volition team and speaking of
volition and getting back to your
question um i can tell you that volition
took a really fresh approach to saints
row this time around i think it's
evident by that awesome trailer that
they went back to the drawing board and
essentially created everything from
scratch we got new characters new city
new gangs to take on the whole deal
so i play the boss that's the character
that the player becomes and the boss
along with their three friends nina
kevin and eli the whole group right
there uh they go on this wild ride to
create their own criminal empire to be
self-made that's their whole mantra
right basically it's all about earning
your own success
you mentioned uh the city we can see it
behind us tell us a bit about this city
where is it what is it uh well volition
created this brand new uh super vibrant
awesome fictional city called santo
alesso it's set in the american
southwest and this city is just
absolutely riddled with violence and
crime and you're thrown right in the
thick of it right off the bat driving
shooting fighting you know just hustling
your way to the top whichever way you
choose and um it's really looking like
santa laso is the biggest and best
saints row playground that they've ever
created it's really awesome you
mentioned all the activity in the city
obviously we have to ask about gangs
rivals what can you tell us about the
the action in the city right well we
have three main gangs and they already
have a really strong hold over santo
laso um and one of them los panteros you
actually saw in the trailer just then
and uh all of the gangs are
incredibly dangerous but that goes
without saying right and they're really
strong and they're all really different
from one another in interesting ways
they're all unique from one another and
the point is which i think everyone can
guess you gotta
fight them and defeat them all to reach
your goals
well uh we are excited to learn more
about this game i think i'm saying
everything that everyone online is
saying it's like but we want to see the
game right you got anything more for us
yes i actually do i've got another
exclusive for y'all you know got to keep
everybody hyped for this reboot so i got
a little taste of what the game actually
looks like so buckle up and get ready
for another wild ride with saints row
amazing bryce charles thank you so much
for joining us here it is a little sneak
preview of the gameplay of saints row
this is where all our dreams come true
[Music]
you